اكاذيب مخزيه تلك هي العباره التي اختارت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان
تستخدمها لوصف تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجيو لافروب قبل يومين والتي لم
يكتفي فيها بانتقاد معتبره تدخلا فرنسيا
في الشؤون الداخليه للدول الافريقيه بل
اتهم باريس بتعزيز الارهابي في القاره
السمراء من خلال دعمها من وصفهم
بالارهابيين في ليبيا
تصريحات راس الدبلوماسيه الروسيه التي
اطلقها خلال جوله له في دول افريقيا
جاءت هي بدورها ردا على تعليق لرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرو في الثالث
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري اجاب فيها عن
رايه بطلب بوركينا فاسو من قوات بلاده
مغادره اراضيها الرئيس ماكرون ساره عبي
توجيه اصابع اتهام وان بطريقه غير مباشره
الى موسكو بالوقوف وراء ذلك الطلب في
الروس برايه متخصصون بالتلا في تلك
المنطقه ولا سيما ان الطلب حكام المستعمره
الفرنسيه السابقه جاء بعد ايام قليله على
احتجاجات شعبيه طالبت برحيل الجنود
الفرنسيين متهمه اياهم باتخادل في حمايه
المدنيين من الجماعات المسلحه وهي ترفع
الاعلام الروسيه رغم ان العلاقات بين
موسكو وباريس تمر اصلا بحاله من التوتر
بسبب الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وتصاعد
الدعم العسكري الغربي لكيف فان لهذه
التجاذبات الدلاله اعمق داخل المشهد
الافريقي
وتحديدا اكثر فيما تعرفه بدول الساحل
فمقابله ما يمكن وصفه بالوفول الفرنسيه
هناك يحضر تمدد الروسي لا تخطئه العين سبق
ان حدث هذا في مالي قبل اشهر واليوم ما
يتكرر في بوركينا فاسو اذ لا يستبعد ان
يحلوا قاتلو مليشاجر بدلا من الجنود
الفرنسيين الذين انتظروا ان يغادر اراضيها
خلال شهر واحد